Her low freak bitches.
Do you put the chains on man,
right.
Sweats off.
Put those genes out right now,
Brian and a pair of the barbell jeans,
so props to barbell jeans.
Eddie Brown was just took it
the second large glass of Vino.
If you were in a fine restaurant,
it's a double son.
Come on most of course.
Wine glass.
He pours a slight sipping thing.
It's a,
this is a delicious wine by the way.
Okay,
let me tell you something about Callin.
This motherfucker knows his one.
I've got a dinner with him and he gets
in a conversation with this shit more.
Yay.
The says,
what do you have in a burgundy
from 97 d and The guy goes,
oh shit.
This motherfucker is for real.
Talking about different comp,
different grapes that are grown on
different hillsides and he'll explain,
he'll explain some shit we were at.
We ate at this restaurant
and the small we AA was like,
yes,
correct.
That's correct.
Correct.
He started,
he started talking about,
oh my God,
I got to work on your technique.
You'd side kick is you
got to pick your knee up.
I think John Claude van Damme,
where those two though,
for sure you have to
put your knee up higher.
They look good and it's nothing.
It's nothing to do with stretching.
It's just you just haven't
thrown a sidekick in a while.
A little rusty.
You can do it,
but you gotta put your
socks on before he came.
People ask,
why do you want to put your socks on?
Does that help your kicking?
You want to put a shoe on?
Oh,
you like to kick with shoes on.
Do you still wear those shiny shoes so
that you could throw a roundhouse kicks
quicker?
Cause you pivot if you have a shiny Sol,
like that's terrible.
You got to pick your knee up.
Nope.
See it's not bad,
but you have an inherent flaw in your
technique that probably was never,
never explained to you for 49 million.
Ain't bad.
It's pretty good.
It's not right.
I wouldn't want to get hit by that.
I wouldn't want to get hit by
in the shower.
That's where you would get hit shit.
Oh Shit.
What's going on
Brian?
Stone spinning kicks,
right.
No Shit.
Dude.
It's wrong.
Those sounds,
those genes are hell.
I used to being serious there.
Are you being serious?
Show me what?
Show me a real front.
Like psychic for real.
All Bullshit.
No bullshit.
Well,
just this,
just throw it.
Sure.
Let me see the spinning one though.
The Woods show him spinning one.
Yeah,
that's my favorite that he does.
It's my favorite.
Too old tear you.
You just all you have to do different.
The all you're doing wrong.
It's,
you're coming up.
Your foot is going up from the ground
like an almost like a half moon,
right?
Yeah.
You want to get your knee up higher.
That's one of the cool things about jeans.
Way Higher than that.
You're are the cool
things about those genes,
those genes,
these genes that were wearing,
they're like sweat pants,
man.
You,
she just had no,
no,
no.
Don't throw the kick
until your knee is up.
Get your knee up first
and then throw the kick.
The problem is you're doing
both at the same time.
No,
no,
no.
Don't throw the kick
until your knees up high.
Lift your knee up way
high past your waist,
and then throw the kick.
Yes,
me up first.
And then don't look over your stomach.
Look over your shoulder.
Yeah,
but me first here.
Hold on.
This fucking hysterical.
This is ridiculous.
This is so sad
is when I'm drunk.
I can't watch.
I can't watch
my part.
Pumped.
Joe is going to go off,
dude.
Genes on genes,
on genes.
Egg Up,
up here,
up the show.
Flexible.
Quite companion from here.
Turn your shoulder to the right.
Turn your shoulder to
the right to the right.
Now extent extension.
Extense straight.
Don't look over your stomach.
Look over your shoulder like this.
Like that.
That's how you look.
I know that's not the end.
That's the flexible,
flexible.
You're fine right from here.
Watch.
Oh,
sons.
Okay.
Damn.
Even in the fucking Chuck Norris is lush.
You lift your knee up and then kick.
I still think John Claude van Damme
beats the fuck out of both of you first.
Then kick watch that one too.
Okay.
Ready?
So I'm not mad at Joe's format.
All right.
No,
no one and then two.
One.
All right,
Eddie,
can you do play by play?
Shit.
Don't look over your stomach.
I don't know what the fuck is wrong.
Well,
I know John Claude van
Damme would be proud.
What are you telling your shoulder?
Look,
I'm throwing it up here.
Yeah,
I'm like this.
Okay.
I'm never like this.
Look at Joe's ass.
When he throws the kick,
it's just looking at it.
Don't look,
don't look at the foot.
He has a set of hunting.
You look at the foot honeydews
on them right into the glutes.
Looking deeply into them.
Dude,
I'd love to see our
actual taekwondo match.
Shrink Callen and relevant.
It's better.
I would just stare at their asses.
Do my Barbara.
Okay.
Fucking monster.
They're awesome,
right?
Yeah.
Well you see my kicks.
You see my
fundamentally a little off.
Yeah,
a little bit.
He's been here so you get there,
but that dose does,
that spin here is everybody fucks.
Everybody fucks that up.
It's a number one thing about the side
kick that people get wrong and it changes
everything.
If you learn as you it right,
you wanted to get that knee up high.
The power differences.
Fucking substantial.
No,
no,
no.
You just got to do it right.
[inaudible] with Rogan's help,
you could be the best.
Kick yourself,
dear diary today.
Listen.
Yeah.